Hey potty mouths, I’m Trace and this is
a frickingDNews Short.
We’ve talked before about the history of
swearing and how it can relieve physical pain.
And new research published in the journal
Social Psychological and Personality Science
found that people who swear more are associated
with higher levels of honesty and integrity!
F*** yeah!
I’m super honest!
Since swearing is a form of self-expression,
the researchers say those who do it more are
portraying themselves more honestly than those
who refrain.
So, if you swear like a sailor (and I know
I do), you’re probably more honest than
people who swear less or don’t swear at
all!
In the study, 276 participants told researchers
how much they swear in their daily lives.
They were then given a questionnaire which
assesses a person’s honesty using what they
call a “Lie Scale.”
By comparing those results with the person’s
level of swearing, the researchers found that
swearing was associated with higher levels
of honesty.
In another part of the study, the researchers
analyzed over 73,000 Facebook statuses from
74,000 willing individuals in the United States.
The statuses were run through software that
was programmed to find swear words and words
that indicate deception.
Once again, those who swore more tended to
tell the truth.
And there are other studies that may back
these findings.
For example, in criminal cases, innocent suspects
were more likely to curse than guilty suspects
when denying accusations!
Plus, people who swear during jury testimonies
are perceived to be more credible!.
So the next time your mom yells at you for
swearing, just say you were being honest!
Science says that's ok.
See how that goes.
Speaking of lying, is it ever ok to lie?
Check out this video to find out.
What do you think about these new findings?
Do you think people who are swearing are most
honest?
Let us know down in the fricken comments and
make sure you subscribe for more DNews.